we're going to look at a short story by
jean-paul sartre
called wall which bears on some of the
history of his own time and you may find
interesting for that reason but it also
expresses certain existentialist themes
that are really central to his
philosophy so what start is doing in a
lot of his stories and plays is taking
the philosophy that he has worked out at
great length and applying it within real
relatively real life situations to see
how people would actually live out this
kind of thing or experience this kind of
thing so this is a short story in 2012
death we'll talk about why moment and
it's about whether life itself has a
meaning or not or whether it has give to
it or whether it's absurd it's also
about a hostile bureaucratic type of
existence and the reason why is because
it's going to look at the site it's the
Spanish Civil War this is a time of
conflict in Spain in which a lot of
people got involved including volunteers
from the fascist side from Germany and
Italy and also communists became
involved or anarchists there were all
sorts of other people there are people
who actually had no political state per
se and identifies a party we got swept
up within as
forced to choose sides and it's one of
those cases where like George Orwell
writes about you know on both sides
atrocities were taking place and not
just atrocities in a physical with the
injuring people or damaging people and
torturing them but the truth itself you
know the way people thought about it
it's the way people talked about things
he would say you know newspaper articles
and they would refer to events that he
hadn't happened and you know trumpet
death as being these great victories and
though they would ignore things that
were actually and so it's kind of an
existence in which it doesn't only
matter how people feel or what their
true value of it is or anything like
that it's just what can be done on paper
about it and you see that a little bit
in the officers as they're approaching
things
so starting Spanish Civil War and nobody
has to do with three prisoners who are
about to be executed they're on the
wrong side in this particular area and
they have been found guilty not with any
sort of real trial or anything like
that's wartime and they're going to be
executed they're going to be shot
they're stuck waiting for this to happen
one of them is name is Pablo he is the
main character of this story he's the
one through whose eyes we see what's
going on one of them is Tom an Irishman
who volunteered there were a lot of
volunteers coming from France from
England from Ireland who fought in the
Spanish Civil War on the side of the
anti-fascist and then there's one
younger young
very you know just right out of
adolescence who himself about to be
executed all three of these prisoners
are being executed there's a few other
characters who have some sort of
importance one is this Belgian doctor
who shares that herself with them for a
certain amount of time who is really
carrying out some some sort of
experiments and observations with them
there are the soldiers and officers
themselves the people you know who are
going to execute them the people who are
passing judgment on them with people who
are confining them and then there's this
guy who never actually shows up in the
story but who the story is certainly is
about at least as far as poeple is
concerned and that's a robbery and he is
a guy he's a he's a fighter and Pablo is
being interrogated in part because they
want to find out where this guy is
staying so that they can kill her so
that's the situation and the time that
the story starts there's a very brief
beginning to it where he says they
pushed us into a white a big white room
and I began to blink because the light
hurt my eyes and it's not a table of the
four men seated behind the table
civilians looking with the papers they
bunched another group of prisoners in
the back and went across the whole room
to join them there were several I knew
and some others who must have been
foreigners the two in front of me were
blondes wrong skulls they looked like I
suppose they did they were French
smaller one kept inching hitching up his
pants he lasted about three hours
Anthony talks about what was going on
the guards brought the prisoners up to
the table one after the other the four
men gasp each one his name and
occupation most of the time they didn't
go any further or they would simply ask
20 here in the air did you have anything
to do with the sabotaging conditions
they didn't listen to the answers as he
says or at least didn't seem to they
were quiet for a moment and then looking
straight in front of them began to write
so again bureaucratic existence there
are these civilians who are sort of pass
with judgment deciding you look over
here you over here you live it'll die
and they seem to have a preconceived
ideas about what you know people are
going to do they asked Tom if it were
true that he were that he was in the
International Brigade Tom couldn't tell
otherwise because he get papers in his
coat that says though they didn't want
anything but they wrote for a long time
after he's well known because they my
brother Hosea is the anarchist
once said you know he isn't here any I
don't belong to any party I never had
anything to do with politics and then
one says I haven't done anything I don't
want to pay for someone else and so a
guard shuts a month and they passed her
to them then finally it's palpable stir
and they say your name is Pablo in viata
yes the man looks at the papers and
asked me where's Ramon Ruiz
I remember you get hidden in your house
from the sixth to the nineteenth no they
wrote for a minute on the guards took me
up so that is a depiction of the entire
interaction that's deciding a man's fate
life or death you know did you do this
no well you're gonna be executed anyway
and they don't even tell them at that
point so finally he asked the guards you
know was that the cross-examination of
the sentence the guard said that was the
sentencing what are they gonna do with
us the guard says they'll read it to you
and yourself so they take them down to
this hospital cellar which is very cold
and
Thomas wagon it says we're screwed and
Pablo says yeah I think you're right or
we are screwed but they're not going to
do anything to the kid and then they it
goes into this story where tom is
telling about what these these people
you know did to save bullets and killing
prisoners and then it goes through a
whole discussion about in a time and
what he was doing trying to sort of you
know keep occupied still warm finally
the major comes in and he holds a sheet
of paper in his hand he asked the guard
what are the names of these three
Steinbeck in Vienna and nerve all the
major to put out his eyeglasses
Steinbach oh yeah you're sentenced to
death you'll be shot tomorrow morning
the other two as well so I can very
bureaucrat eyes alienating existence
that they're caught up in the major
doesn't even see them see them feel
anything wrong with this you're gonna
know yeah you're gonna be executed see
you later
that matters a lot to these guys doesn't
at least you know have a start so what's
going on here
this is a story of fundamentally about
death and the meaning that people who
are going to a court to death yeah one
of the important things to keep in mind
in this it's not just sort of a
conceptual meaning this is an
existential level story so the meaning
of death that the characters encounter
is not just a matter of how they think
about death it's a matter of how they
feel about death or about how death
pervades their existence and causes them
to feel certain ways it's also because
it's about death it's about time because
they're not yet death and they have a
certain you know time that is being
occupied during which they
not that one existing what is going on
with this last bit of their existence
and I think the best way to look at this
story is in part if we want to look at
it in terms of the philosophy behind it
and not just a little literary are two
things that though we should look at
each one of the characters and how they
approach to how they see done and so
we're not actually going to start with
pop pop will exemplifies I think what
you can argue to be the orientation
towards death that start with most
identified with Tom and one are showing
us ways of viewing one's death that
Sartre considers have something wrong
you know again Sartre doesn't really
have an ethics so in a certain
perspective you'd say well everybody's
going to die and you decide what you're
gonna do with it but sark does have at
least the rudiments outlines of an
ethics and he thinks that there are
certain orientations towards our
existence towards death towards meaning
towards life towards freedom towards
choice that if we're looking at things
from an existentialist perspective we
should adopt things this way we should
be consistent with ourselves you
shouldn't live in delusion and so I
think you can say that tongue and wand
are both people who are in a certain
respect feeling according to certain
standards the Belgian doctor is also
doing so he's not about died but he's
there and he's got an orientation
towards death so let's look at each one
of those
characters in turn first before we
actually look at one and his own
peculiar orientation before we look at
Pablo so let's look at one first why
does a young man Pablo is a actually
kind of disgusted with it what happens
first is you know tom has kind of scared
the kid by talking about you know doing
these these awful things that the
prisoners rather than shooting them just
to save on ammunition
so one is already a little bit concerned
about this and Belgian doctor is about
to show up and Tom says what did I tell
weekend and then Pablo says yes it's a
rotten deal for the kid here we get to
see how Pablo sees one I said that to be
decent but I didn't like the kid his
face was too thin and the fear and
suffering had disfigured twisting all
those features three days before he was
a smart sort of kid not too bad but now
his face is transformed I thought how
we'd never be young again even if they
were to let him go death you see this is
the theme of death transforms people not
just the action of death you know that
trauma transforms you from being a
living breathing being to something
that's just you know meet later on the
table or in the yard it transforms the
person who is encountering it and really
taking it on as a live possibility for
the first time it wouldn't have been too
hard to have a little pity for him the
pity disgusts me
or rather horrifies me he hadn't said
anything morbid he turned a grades hands
and facial fourth grade he sat down
again and looked at the
with round eyes the kid starts you know
you know Tom tries to you know be nice
to the kid tears himself away yeah Pablo
says let them alone you can see his baby
blogger he's going to cry it's going to
be an emotional reaction so Tom a bit
regretfully he would like to comfort the
kid yeah that's that's telling it a
little bit about one later on one
actually needs to speak for himself
yeah why does talking to the doctor who
says so you're a doctor does it hurt
very long yeah the doctor kind of you
know was trying to comfort him and he
says but but I lips as' they told me
sometimes they have to fire twice then
they have to reload their rifles and a
mile over again he thought for a moment
to me unfortunately that takes time
what's going on here well start tells us
he had a terrible fear of suffering it's
all he thought it was his age I never
thought much about it it wasn't a fear
of suffering that made me sweat so in a
certain respect why precisely because
he's not yet mature he is unable to
think about things in the bigger picture
he's not actually thinking about death
in terms of hey I'm going to stop
existing he's thinking about the
physical pain that bullets shot into you
who's going to [ __ ] with the bird he's
worried that it's going to take too long
you know you get the idea that if they
had offered one possibility of taking a
pill killing mints
you could do that what else a little bit
later one is starting to come apart and
the Belgian doctor comes up to him and
says the the Belgian doctor went over to
little one did he want to feel this net
for some professional motive or was he
obeying and impulsive charity if he was
acting by charity it was going to end
during the whole night he crashed ones
pad and deck the kid let himself be
ended his eyes never leaving him then
suddenly he sees the hand and looked at
it strangely he held the belt his hand
between his two hands he held the belt
once again between his own two hands and
there was nothing Pleasant about them to
great pincers gripping this fat and
reddish and I suspect that what was
going to happen and Thomas a suspect
that a typically the Belgium didn't see
a thing
he smiled paternally so he the Belgian
doctor is in there he does not
experience him death right he's not
experiencing an existential if you study
it objectively walk is now coming to
terms of the fact that hey I'm gonna
stop her and maybe even he's realized
he's gonna die and one now he has the
doctors hand after a moment the kid
brought the fat run hand to his mouth
and tried to fight it the Belgian pulled
away quickly and stumbled against the
wall for a second he looked at us before
he must have suddenly understood we were
not men like him we were no longer the
same thing human beings death even
before they died is transforming them
one like I said is coming to pieces he
is viewing death in terms of physical
soccer and he's trying to avoid it he
doesn't want to paint
what else does
well a little bit later on again
provoked by the Belen doctor little Juan
began to cry he wrung his hands and
pleaded I don't want to die I don't want
to die he ran across the whole cellar
waving his arms in the air that smell
sobbing another man's Tom watched it
with warm flies without the slightest
desire to consoling
because it wasn't worth the trouble the
kid made more noise that we did but he
was less touched this is a great
description he was like a sick man who
defends himself against his illness by
fever it's much more serious when there
isn't any to you he wept I could see he
was pitting himself he wasn't thinking
about death
for one second one single second I
wanted to weep myself to weep the pity
for myself but the opposite happened I
glanced at the kid I saw his thin Sabich
shoulders than I felt in him and I could
pity me the others or myself so what was
going on one is great pain and being
afraid of the pain allows him to not
thinking love them to a babe consider it
yeah that's coming and he's feeling self
p41 you know he didn't do anything the
world is unfair brother who was the
anarchist so this is one orientation
towards death and towards suffering that
a person can and this is long that
Sartre seems to think is not a very good
orientation they have because you're
concealing from yourself the fact that
you know death is right around the
corner there's a presence of possibility
present all the time and you want to
come to terms with it how much time well
Tom instead of crying or anything like
that you know from the start he he tries
to keep himself busy he tries to wrap
his head around things you know like he
says when when poeple says leave leave
the kid alone
Tom obeyed regrettably he would have
liked to comfort the kid it would have
passed his time and he wouldn't have
been tempted to think about himself and
then he talks you know to to pop what
he's talking about physics place it says
you know you think you think you've
knocked guys off to you
he explained that
six since the beginning of the longest
he didn't realize the situation that I
could tell he didn't watch with realize
he wants to talk about other things he
does exercise and all that what happens
over time well yeah
certain point he cannot keep himself so
this orientation that breaks down and
then he doesn't start thank you Sartre
says he began to talk to himself he
never stopped watching the Belgium the
building didn't seem to be listening to
the balcony
Tom says it's like a nightmare you want
to think something you always have the
impression that it's alright but you're
going that you're going to understand
and then it slips it escapes going fades
away I tell myself there will be nothing
afterwards but I don't understand what
it means okay so what's going on here
tom is actually trying to wrap his head
around the reality of death of nothings
of the negation or the annihilation of a
human being and not just on any other
human beings but of the human being that
he is of the subject that he's trying to
imagine what things will be like without
him so he's trying to imagine something
that's not really
strictly speaking imaginable because
he's trying to put himself into a
situation that he's not in by definition
because he's gonna die since I told
myself there will be nothing afterwards
but I don't understand what that means
sometimes I can and then it fades away I
start thinking about all the same stuff
that Juan was thinking you've got the
beans again bullets explosions I'm a
materialist I swear to you I'm not going
crazy but something's the matter
I see my corpse that's not her but I'm
the little seasoned with miles again to
think think that I'm gonna see anything
anymore in the world will go on for the
others we aren't made to think that
believe me I've already stayed up all
night waiting for something this isn't
the Saints will creep up behind us Pablo
and we won't be able to prepare for it
so what's going on here Sartre is
placing in the mouth suppose we
materialist the realization about the
the nature of not just death but our
understanding of death the antes
experiencing problems conceptualized
imagination wrapping his head around
feeling his weight right why well he
hasn't thought about it much before now
he's been a guy who's been killing other
people right he killed eight you know
six people since August but death has
been something for him perhaps like an
adventure to not really like a hateful
reality that you can't can't afford it
supposed to
a little bit further on something
happens with time Tom still talking yeah
Pablo says you know naturally I agree
with him I could have said everything he
it isn't natural to die and since I was
going to die nothing seemed natural to
me only it didn't please me to think the
same things as Tom and I knew that all
through the night every five minutes
would keep on thinking things at the
same time I looked at him sideways and
for the first time he seemed strangely
he wore death on his face my prime is
wounded for the past 24 hours I live
next to Tommy I'd listen to him I'd
spoken to him and I knew we had nothing
in common and now who looked as much
alike as twin brothers simply because we
were ready to die together
Tom took my Hannah thought looking at me
Pablo and wondered I wonder if it's
really true that everything that's and
then here's where something happened
Sartre is using this as you know it's
very realistic but it's also sort of a
metaphor I took my hand away and said
look between your feet you Pig there's a
big puddle between the street and drops
ball in his pants like he's urinated all
over himself out of fear out of fear
over the fact that he's going to duck
he's no longer actually fully aware of
his body he's losing control over his
bodily functions he says what is it
you're pissing in your pants I'm told it
isn't true said furiously I'm not
pissing I don't feel anything
and Tom says I don't know what it is but
I'm not afraid of swear I'm not afraid
so this is sort of emblematic
towards a little bit of racing here so
what is what is the orientation that a
human being has for its death what are
the possibilities that one can has
wanted done focus on what precedes death
so we had one can of the Ring here where
it's the supper before the death takes
place one can try to do so this is one
and this is also time for service Pablo
is trying to figure out what's going to
happen after death adapted oneself or
not any longer
and we strive to man place himself
beyond there in imagination of the
trouble with this is that you might say
it's
seeing because you're assuming the kind
of subject where a person there who is
hearing out of the imagination right
you're trying to get a view of yourself
while you're gone so there's an
instability there are you there or are
you going to try to imagine the actual
annihilation of you but then there's no
you to actually do the imagine we had so
this is what he says it's kind of on the
end so there's a fear of the software
and there's fear of the non-existence
what else is possible timing that goes
out a little bit further with it with
Tom Tom actually becomes kind of
concerned with what is happening
Tom you know starts realizing at same
time that one does that time is running
hours and he starts to become concerned
with what's going on the possibility are
Isis
Tom had got not be placed himself just
under the round opening and begun to
watch her daily I was determined to die
clean the animal he thought of that but
ever since the doctor told us the time I
thought the time flying boy would drop
by drop it was still dark when I heard
Tom's voice do you hear them what the
hell are they doing they can't shoot in
the dark
after a while we heard no more I said
the town it's dead it's starting at full
time they must do it in the court in the
rear and says do you realize what's
happening they call his name and they
take about what he happens to Tom Tom
who was up between two soldiers two
others followed hearing the kid by the
armpits he hadn't fainted his eyes were
wide open and tears ran down his chief
tom was actually going to his death you
know fairly good fashion the kid is just
like totally these are different
orientations I'm looking at that one can
you have fun stuff now before we look at
the other possible orientation towards
it let's look at the Belgian doctor this
is no longer a subjective orientation
towards death this is a more detached
objective orientation so the Belgium
doctor comes then and he offers them
what they'd like to get out during that
time he says
by animator disposal I shall do all I
can to make it live your last moments
less difficult yeah it says I was sent
here
would you like to smoke I have
cigarettes and even cigars and they say
I don't even want anything to do with
you you're a fascist you are with them
what's he do then starts examining and
his taking observation stuff so he goes
to one and Belgium he says I saw the
Belgians he interrupts stealthily long
Tom wads arm down to the wrist one big
no attention the Belgian took his wrist
between three fingers distractedly at
the same time drawing back the little
attorneys back to me but I mean
backwards an Assad take a watch from his
pocket look at for a moment never
letting go over the wrist after a minute
he let the ant fallen dirt and went and
leaned his back against the wall that is
if he suddenly remembered something very
important which had to be jotted down on
the spot he took out a notebook from his
pocket and wrote down a few lines
bastard I'll show my business records so
he's easy actually he was taking
measurements of these people who are
dying and he's trying to conceal the
fact from why why would you actually
hide them he's carrying out an
experiment he wants to understand what
people are going through when they're
facing death and he's focusing on the
body on the physiology not soul of their
psyche or anything like that he starts
you know examining the others and he
says to to Pablo doesn't it seem cold to
you here policy I'm not cold
he never took his heart eyes wofully
suddenly understood my hands went to my
face I was drenched
so he's making Pablo realized that he's
having a physical reaction himself he
says that swine of a Belgian he hadn't
missed a thing can see that drops
rolling down my chief said he thought
this is the man of the station with an
almost pathological state of terror and
he had felt more more than proud of
being alive because he was cold so the
Falcon is really distancing himself from
these and what is the Belgian trying to
do to look at a state of terror you know
during that time before they doubt he
wants them to just study them a little
bit later
Tampere doubt tongue Pablo characterizes
that again he says the Belgian didn't
seem to be listening to Tom talking he
knew what he had come to do he wasn't
interested in what we thought he had
come to watch our bodies Bonnie is dying
in agony well he had a lot so what is he
looking at he's looking at a death the
existence our bodies dying in agony
while still alive he's observing this
trying to learn about mystery the
mystery of death there's a realization
as well this has already been talked
about a little bit that they are no
longer that like him that there's a gap
between the life the experience
existence of the Belgian doctor who's
made of
next day and these three men were
condemned to death
towards the end he offers to take a
message to their loved ones yeah again
this is the sort of thing sort of like
trying to carry out an existence past
your death well you're going to die but
I'll carry a little bit of you do to
your loved ones and then finally towards
the very end he does something that Papa
thinks is just you know terrible and
he's doing it deliberately the Belgian
took out his watch he looked at it he
said it's 3:30 bastard he must have done
it on purpose Tom jumped we hadn't
noticed that time's running out so the
public doctrine is restoring his
connection to in time and terror so that
he can observe he's provoking them every
so often he is not just observed he's
trying to place them in their last
moments even when he's trying to you
know pretend like he's doing something
nice for them doing something carrying
something sympathetic he is again part
of this bureaucratic existence that
they're stuck with so those are those
three orientations for his death no
let's look at what it is that the Pablo
says because what we're getting as far
as service concerns is coming not just
through these guys but especially
through the main character what does he
tell us when it comes to death
Pablo says that he's never really
thought about it before he says you know
Tom didn't really want to think about
this
and he says I hadn't quite realized it
myself I wondered if it hurt much I
thought of bullets I imagined there
burning hell through my mind all that
was beside the real question but but I
was called we have all night to
understand so another possibility is
trying to attain understand what does
the math today understand we had all
night to understand how will you
understand this will it be through
terror will it be view fear will it be
through this attempt to picture
something that can't be a little bit
later when he's talking about the the
sweating and all that sort of stuff he
says that it's not really the fear of
suffering that's making him sweat you
know one is a terrible fear of suffering
but I don't really have that he says
something else was making me me sweat a
little bit further on he starts having
some physical manifestations he says
they're talking about what its gonna be
like when they get shot and I said you
know it's gonna hurt a lot you know
sometimes they came at the eye to the
mouth of disfigure you tom says I can
fill the wounds already I've had pains
in my head into my neck for the past
hour
not real beings worse this is what I'm
going to feel tomorrow morning and then
so again the song but it's being
imagining that makes it worse publicist
said well understood what he meant but I
didn't want to act as if I did I had
pains - pains in my body like a crowd of
tiny scars I couldn't get used to it but
I was like him I attached it on
accordance to it after I said you'll be
pushing up daisies
so he's what's going on here Pablo
actually is developing a certain
transcendence of these things you know
Juan is so identified with his body that
he can only think in terms until the
very end the suffering that his body is
going to experience tom is going back
and forth he's trying to imagine the
death but he also become wavers feels
physical fear urinates all over himself
because of its there it's not just you
know existential fear but it's an actual
physical body papa was developing a kind
of transcendence with the body itself
that doesn't mean that his body isn't
going through the same things
induced by terror they're a little bit
later he talks about not feeling
sympathy for these other people he
doesn't like Tom he doesn't like why and
he says fundamentally I didn't have much
sympathy
and I didn't see why I'm the pretext of
dying together I should have anymore it
would have been different with some
others so he does feel that he could
have solidarity with certain other
people like who Remo and Greece for
example but I felt alone between Tom and
one I like that better anyhow with
Ramona I might have been more deeply
moved but I was terribly hard just then
and I wanted to stay hard I wanted to
stay detached Luke to engage in
transcendence once again to put up a
very strong front for however long it
could go on a little bit later he says
that death doesn't really make any sense
says I was relaxed and overexcited at
the same time I didn't want to think any
more about what would happen at dawn at
death it made no sense I'm trying to
understand I'm not trying to imagine it
I'm trying to understand it I found only
words for emptiness this is again a very
common theme in Sark
you see this coming up in nausea and in
other words by themselves there are only
symbols and they may not actually
effectively capture what is going on and
we shouldn't take those symbols as if
they are the actors yeah or emptiness
nothing else something we can't really
wrap our heads around as soon as I try
to think of anything else
I saw rifle barrels running at me
perhaps I'd live through my execution
once they even thought of us were good
he started dreaming right and that he
goes through this experience this is a
very important passage in the world now
I was starting to have some sort of
fundamental experience of what it's
going to mean that he's waiting time he
says the crowded memories came back to
being pell-mell there were good ones and
bad ones where at least they called them
that before so we mentioned this theme
several times ago but the human being on
the way to facing down there's a certain
kind of break that occurs certain kind
of change no longer being the same kind
of human being yes and doctor was going
to live before this occurs papa was able
to call some of these memories good and
some of these memories bad after this
occurs they're just memories
they've been their values have been
stripped away so there's a stripping
away meaning there's a stripping away of
value he says there were faces and
incidents he goes through a lot of
examples I'm not going to go through all
of these at that moment I felt that my
whole I had my whole life in front of me
and I thought it's a damn lie it was
worth nothing because it was finished I
wondered how I'd been able to walk to
laugh at the girls I wouldn't have moved
so much as my little finger if I'd only
imagined I would die like so what's
going on the death or Pablo you might
say
values it's not just an extinction of a
human being it's that the world loses
its values
it loses good bad evil ugly beautiful
everything is reduced to just no values
just things as they are he says my life
was in front of me shut clothes like a
bag and yet everything inside it was
unfinished for an instant I tried to
judge it I wanted to tell myself this is
a beautiful life but I couldn't pass
judgment on it was only a sketch I had
spent my time as a beautiful life I've
spent my time counterfeiting eternity I
had understood nothing I had missed
nothing there were so many things I
could have missed but I didn't death had
disenchanted everything that's a good
way to put death and taken away the
illusion for starts character of things
in the world actually having value why
well because once the human being dies
there's nothing else there to give them
value and if it's my memories my life my
experiences only I am here to give them
the value that they have my projects my
desires once I'm gone whatever existence
they have and they have written them
down or you know recorded them somewhere
they no longer have any moral or
aesthetic or any other sort of value
no human they have just bare existence
that small that's that's left to them a
little bit later he talks about in his
death you know death being everywhere
seeing it everywhere objects start
taking out a funny look it's affecting
his physical perception yeah he says I
couldn't think clearly about my death
but I saw it everywhere up things and
the way things
at the distance discreetly as people who
speak quietly at the bedside of the
dying man in the state I was in
if somebody had come and told me I could
go home quietly that they would leave my
life whole it would have left me cold
several hours or several years of
waiting is the same when you have lost
the illusion of deep eternal so what is
going on he has attained an
understanding that things don't have
their values that human beings are not
eternal that he is not eternal and that
whether he dies in five minutes or five
hours five weeks five years or five
hundred years it's all the same life it
has lost its meaning for him death on
the other hand is visible everywhere
he's become conscious of existentially
conscious not just you know conscious of
the sense of well I know more that I
would die someday he's becoming
existentially aware of it and this leads
us to the sort of date amount of this
this story the finish how does it
actually end well one and Tom are taken
out and they're executed there's more to
the story for Pablo the officers take
him and they start to interrogate him
again and what do they want they want
the same information they wanted before
where is Remo agrees and he doesn't want
to give it to them and he's got a great
line here where he's talking about them
trying to scare him trying to threaten
him with death they don't realize by
putting him in this situation
they've lost any hold on him that they
had making tough or
why would have done whatever they
couldn't get a couple more minutes
that's not gonna be the case of Pablo
because now if you realize the mask has
been pulled off the veil is his remnant
he says you know we're gonna make you a
deal this is what the officers are
saying we'll let you live but you have
to tell us where it reads and he says I
don't worry as I thought he was in
Madrid the other officer raised his pale
en intimately this indolence was also
calculated I saw through all their
little schemes and I was stupefied to
find that there were men who abused
themselves that way you have a quarter
of an hour to think about take him to
the laundry to bring him back in 15
minutes if he still refuses he'll be
executed on the spot they knew what they
were doing I passed the night waiting
then they made me wait an hour in the
cellar while they shot Tom and Juan and
now they were locking me up with the
laundry
they must have prepared their game the
night before they told themselves that
nerves eventually wear off and they hope
to get me that way they would badly
mistake in the laundry i sat on a stool
because I felt very weak and I started
to what did he think about so I didn't
think about their proposition of course
I knew where Brees was he was fighting
with his cousins for kilometers from the
city I also knew that I would not reveal
his hiding place unless they tortured
all that was perfectly regulated
definite and a no way interested only I
would have liked to understand the
reasons for my conduct so now we're
about external things worried about his
own kind
I would rather die than give up grease
one something something has changed
remember erasure of values so he admired
grease before he was ready to lay down
his life for you
now it doesn't value reads anymore now
he says I didn't like Ramon reasonably
my friendship for him and died a little
bit before dawn at the same time as my
desire to live why because that
friendship itself is of the realm of
values undoubtedly I thought highly of
him he was tough but it was not for this
reason I can send it to die in his place
his life had no more value than mine no
boy had value they were going to slap a
man up against the wall and shoot at him
until he died whether it was me or
Greece someone else makes no difference
I knew that he was more useful than I to
the cause of Spain but I thought Elvis
painted Anarchy again that's a matter of
values right and after you detained an
understanding that erases or puts on a
play those values that matter to people
who aren't going to die but in the face
of death no longer matter what can you
appeal to nothing so he's trying to
figure out well why am I still sticking
to this why do I care about this
grieving yet I was there I could save my
skin and give him grease and I refused
to do it
I found that somehow comic it was
obstinate see I thought I must be
stubborn than a drawl sort of gaiety
spent over me know what's going on here
a sort of life orientation of Cascia
stubbornness and it produces a kind of
joy and gave humorousness in him because
he realizes that the only basis I have
now given this understanding that's the
only basis I have for this decision it's
a movie the passion this stubbornness
so they come free and they bring him in
and says have you thought about it and
then what's going on
is he's actually gonna try to play a
joke he says I know where he is he's
hidden in the cemetery it evolved during
the gravedigger chef says I wanted to
see them actually have to go do this I
want to see them stand up buckle their
faults gods of get borders so they do
and they says from time to time I smile
thinking about the spectacle they were
made they felt stunned and malicious I
imagined them lifting up tombstones
opening the doors and balls one by one I
represented this situation of myself as
if I'd been someone else this prisoner
absolutely played the hero the grim
valid Jesus does with their mustaches of
their men in uniform running along the
grates it was irresistible funny so he
does you know there is still a value
left but it's only one which he finds
sort of coming out of himself without
him necessarily choosing or being aware
of it's not a value that he's finding in
the world it's a value that he's finding
himself sort of thrown into and
overcoming him everything else has been
taken away now he's going to have a
little bit of fun after expense before
they kill but the joke's on him because
what actually happens they come back the
officer looked at me you didn't look at
all sheepish take him into the big
courtyard with the others after the
military operations were regular
corporal to decide what to do with them
Pablo asks the they're not going to
shoot me
daddy says not now what happens
afterwards it's none of my business
and what what happened well as it turned
out the reason was in the graveyard
Pablo didn't know Pablo is just you know
through the throwing stuff out at random
trying to make them do as much work as
possible turns out that grieves and left
his cousin's on Tuesday examine argument
so he went to the semi
very he hit there he get squat how does
it end everything began to spin and I
found myself sitting on the ground I
laughed so hard I cried so it it's
interesting it begins in action goes
through this radical existentialist
awareness of death moments depicts the
stripping away of things the very end of
it you know passion comes in a passion
humour gaiety stubbornness perversity
whatever you want to call it and the
twists itself upon him existence itself
shows itself as having a kind of sense
of humor as well and he laughed so hard
that he cries so this is very typically
sorry an existentialist there is no
meaning in life apart from a week of it
and that meaning that we give it is
probably for the most part unsustainable
in the face of death at least most of
that meaning that we give it as
unsustainable in the face of death even
though other people are still sustaining
that meaning because they're not dying
yet yeah in mint that doesn't mean that
it all turns into a complete blank brain
dreary existence there's still the
possibility of something coming out of
us are coming over this a passion that
we can still feel and in a way that's
kind of a hopeful thing to say given us
arts in general a fairly gloomy attitude
towards towards death so once again we
have a narrative a story sort of like
nausea ones where starts philosophy is
actually being represented through the
eyes of the main character we'll see
this again with other surgery and
stories
now